two weeks ago i updated you from this
podium on
the progress we had made as a country in
our fight against
coronavirus and in many ways that
progress continues
the number of patients admitted to
hospitals is still falling and now
stands at just over
100 each day in april there were more
than 3 000
chronovirus patients in mechanical
ventilation beds but now the latest
figure
is 87 the number of deaths continues
to fall and although one is too many
that is obviously
encouraging but i've also
consistently warned that this virus
could
come back and that we would not hesitate
to take swift
and decisive action as required and
i'm afraid that in parts of asia and
latin america the virus is gathering
pace
and some of our european friends are
also struggling
to keep it under control as we see these
rises
around the world we can't fool ourselves
that we
are exempt we must be willing to react
to the first signs of trouble today
the weekly survey by the office for
national statistics reports
that the prevalence of the virus in the
community in england
is likely to be rising for the first
time since
may around one in fifteen hundred now
have the virus compared to one in
eighteen hundred on the fifteenth
of july and one in two thousand on the
2nd
of july the ons also estimate that there
are now
4 900 new infections every day up from
around 3 000 per day on the 14th of july
and 2 000 per day at the end of june we
just can't afford to
ignore this evidence it's vital to
stress of course
that we are in a far better position to
keep
the virus under control now than we were
at the start
of the pandemic but as i say we cannot
be
complacent and i won't stand by and
allow this virus to threaten to cause
more pain
and more heartache in our country so
that's why
last night the health secretary
announced new restrictions on household
contact in the northwest
specifically greater manchester and in
parts of east lancashire
and west yorkshire these are targeted
measures
on social contact between households
which the data tells us is driving the
current
increase in cases businesses and
workplaces should continue
as before in those areas i know
how hard it is to have restrictions like
this imposed
on seeing your family and your friends
but we have to act
rapidly in order to protect those
we love and we know this sort of
intervention works
measures taken in leicester and luton
have suppressed
the virus and allowed us to to relax
measures
and you remember at every point i have
said
our plan to reopen the society and the
economy
is conditional that it relies on
continued progress against the virus
and we would not hesitate to put the
brakes on
if required with those numbers creeping
up our assessment is that we should now
squeeze that brake pedal squeeze that
brake pedal
in order to keep the virus under control
on saturday the 1st of august you'll
remember we had hoped
to reopen in england a number of the
higher risk settings
that had remained closed and today i'm
afraid we're postponing those changes
for at least a fortnight that means
until the 15th of august at the earliest
casinos bowling alleys skating rinks and
the remaining close
contact services must remain closed
indoor performances will not
resume pilots of larger crowds in sports
venues and conference centers will not
take place and wedding receptions of up
to 30 people will not be permitted but
ceremonies of course
can continue to take place in line with
covid
secure guidelines and i know that the
steps that
we're taking will be a real blow to many
people to everyone obviously whose
wedding plans
have been disrupted or who cannot now
celebrate
eid in the way that they would
wish and i'm really really sorry about
that but we simply cannot
take the risk we will of course study
the data carefully
and move forward with our intention to
open up
as soon as we possibly can most people
in this country are following the rules
and doing their best to
control the virus but we must
keep our discipline and our focus
and we cannot be complacent i've asked
the home secretary to work with the
police and others to ensure the rules
which are already in place are properly
enforced that means local authorities
acting to close down premises and cancel
events
which are not following kovid's secure
guidance
and it means a greater police presence
to ensure face coverings
are being worn where this is required by
law
we will also extend the requirement to
wear a face covering to other indoor
settings
where you're likely to come into contact
with people you do not normally meet
such as museums
galleries cinemas and places of worship
we now recommend face coverings are worn
in these settings and this will become
enforceable in law from the 8th of
august
at this stage we are not changing the
rules on social contact
nationally i don't want to tell people
to spend
less time with their friends but unless
people
follow the rules and behave safely
we may need to go further